Kim Kardashian and Kanye West broke down  some serious PDA make me feel some type  away  the happy couple stepped out for a date  night over the weekend looking more  lovey-dovey than ever the duo was  spotted taking a romantic stroll through  LA Kim in a cropped tee long black skirt  and beige booties Kanye and a pair of  work boots ripped jeans and a black  jacket  hashtag twinning the reality star and  her rapper hubby have a lot to smooch  about these days last week a source  close to the couple told et that the  parents of to have hired a surrogate to  carry their third child quote they are  excited to finally add to their family I  am so excited Kim also launched her  k'kaw beauty line which sold out within  a minute I am launching my own makeup  brand we're launching with a contour kit  so it's gonna be cream contour and  highlighters I'm so excited and the  proud parents celebrated their daughter  North's 4th birthday on Saturday